direction l'hôpital de Blois maintenant
là-bas des centaines de patients passent
chaque année par le service de
psychiatrie certains pour plusieurs mois
et sur le chemin de la guérison des
activités qui permettent de créer du
lien social et c'est le cas du basket
avec la participation exceptionnelle
cette semaine des joueurs de l'adnois le
reportage d'Aurélie Renaud
2m10 ça impressionne si les débuts sont
timides dès les premières minutes de
match l'ambiance se réchauffe sur le
terrain des patients de psychiatrie
certains sont là depuis huit mois
d'autres depuis trois semaines ils
partagent cette partie avec deux pros de
l'ADA Blu à basket et quel que soit
niant à l'hôpital c'est un milieu fermé
donc il y a pas des
spectateurs comme on voit ici quoi ou
bien des personnel soignants qui sont
avec nous qui ne supporte une journée un
peu exceptionnelle aujourd'hui
on en fait pas tout le temps comme ça
le terrain de basket a été inauguré à la
rentrée car ici le sport fait partie de
la thérapie à part entière il permet de
diminuer quelques effets secondaires des
médicaments et de renouer avec certaines
sensations ça permet de travailler en
équipe donc les relations
interpersonnelles ça renforce la renvoie
derrière moi je pense plein de sourires
du coup ça aussi c'est important pour
l'estime de soi la reine artistisation
l'importance quand on sort d'une
dépression de pouvoir se remettre aussi
et se rétablir dans de bonnes conditions
si les couloirs de l'hôpital sont à
quelques mètres cette parenthèse
sportive permet à tout le monde de
souffler une pause également pour les
joueurs professionnels avis de rencontre
il fait beau tu t'es bien
je suis bien tranquille vous avez marqué
un panier
et là là voir d'autres personnes ça
permet un peu de relâcher la pression
c'est la pluie qui sonne la fin du match
et durant le goûter chacun s'est fait
une promesse se revoir pour marquer à
nouveau quelques paniers